[Music]
but i think the way you think about an
nft project is
the art comes almost secondary though
it's very important
it's are you willing to give access to
your fans
virtually or physically
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
[Music]
my man
that's amazing how are you
such a pleasure
what's good
good good morning welcome yeah congrats
on everything man
it's [ __ ] crazy
it's been amazing it's crazy to watch
you ascend it's so good
very good
where where were you born
puerto rico puerto rico
it's amazing
it's amazing
no worries how um
how can we help you guys the most
nft's books i know yeah we're just
talking about it all i don't know where
you guys want
all right i mean they were saying that
they want to do an interview they want
to do it right i told them you took your
time they don't want to rush you know
they want to do a book i mean he's on
top of the world and they're just saying
that's crazy let's keep it moving really
i mean the nft thing is
so big
you know everyone gets caught up in how
much money there is right now
it's so much bigger than that because
it's kind of like 1996 97 98 for
internet
you know when the internet came there
was so much money go public
but then in 2000 all the stocks went to
zero
but in all that zero
ebay and amazon were there
and they were meant to be ebay in
arizona and that's what's going to
happen with nfts that's why it's good to
be thoughtful
you've seen it it's been a lot of
artists a lot of important people put
out projects and done [ __ ]
and then there's projects that right now
are doing incredible
that
are vulnerable
because it's a long-term game
but i don't know what your
music deal
or situation is but
as an author
music
funding of movies
all of it is going to be changed because
nfts
as an artist imagine when you're coming
up
this is what we're going to talk a lot
about
instead of taking a bag
from
a record label
right because that's what happens you
build on tick tock you build on
soundcloud
then people come and they offer you
money and you go on a label and that
makes sense if you have no you know it's
not a great business deal
but the upfront money is very valuable i
did the same thing with my books
oh million dollars in for that matter
you know it's money
now instead
the 15 year old you
in seven years
get big on whatever tick-tock is get big
on whatever soundcloud is
put out an nft
with your cover art
of your album
and say these 10 000
nfts of my first album
not only do you get the art
not only does it come with an hour of
zoom where you can meet me or meet in
person
but i'm giving up 20 of my royalties
forever
divided by 10 000
so the fans are gonna become the record
label
not the record label
it's a big
deal it's a crazy it's a crazy to me
so
that you got to put in the back of your
mind because you might be indeed you
know again i don't know where you're at
as far as overall it comes down to who
you are i was perfect for nfts because i
love meeting strangers
but i don't think that makes me nice or
special that's just who i am
i have so many friends who are big
who also want to and then many that
don't and that's okay you don't have to
force it but i think the way you think
about an nft project is
the art comes almost secondary though
it's very important
it's are you willing to give access to
your fans virtually or physically
if the one of one gold one
platinum one
in a series of 100
is dinner with you
it's gonna go for a lot more money than
just the
art yeah
so that that's something to think about
but the nft thing
is like the social media thing this is
not a fad
this is not a quick move
this is forever for i look at everybody
here everyone's young i'll throw myself
in there i'm a little older than you
guys
this is gonna take over our lives
forever
so it's worth thinking about but i think
the way you think about is what are you
willing to give your fans in access
virtually or physically
that's how you go backwards
because the contract underneath the art
is the very special part of nfts
the thing i started with is how it's
going to revolutionize the entire music
industry
it's nfts are the most dangerous thing
to the right more dangerous
than napster
more dangerous
than soundcloud more dangerous than
tick-tock
because the record labels always had the
fact that they were the funding
mechanism of the artist
now you get big on tick tock
and sound cloud and you sell nfts to
your audience
you can raise 5 million overnight
and you can keep 80 percent
instead of giving up 80
and then you know how good it feels when
you pop off
that the [ __ ] people that believed in
you the most are the ones that are
getting money every time you spotify
and for me like like
when i look up when i think about what
we do
you know we just give lu you guys have a
sense of how we do it
mike
mike probably shouldn't be investing in
startups or buying stock
but when this becomes real mike even
while he works for me
the first thing i'll tell him is like
because i love him and he's family i'm
like here's 50k
go buy it when this becomes real in five
years i'm like what you've done for the
last 20 years
when you see the baby or a little baby
or magnus stallion buy those [ __ ]
nfts
because buying those entities is going
to give you royalties
it's going to be changed it's going to
change the world so nfts you have to get
smart you guys
you know you're busier you guys have to
spend hours understanding it because
it's it's not a quick buck
it's not a quick budget that's why i'm
having
smart decisions if you know obviously
obviously we're going to meet for a half
an hour and everyone's busy but if you
need extra time we'll get on zoom i'll
help of course
i'm sure you're getting bombarded check
it out
one
yeah the arts [ __ ] fire i see
yeah it's it's all coming
too many people are fixated on the
visual
and the art's important
but like this is important to me because
it's me
it this doesn't look as good as this
but it's authentic
and you know this i've been watching for
a minute like the reason you got to hear
is because it's authentic
when it's real it's real yeah when it's
not it's not
right
so
so for me when people make fun of me
because they're like gary your art is
like a second grader i'm like cool but
it's me
and i have enough money to hire the best
artists in the world
i could make it look phenomenal but it's
[ __ ] me
then i'll convert them into you ever see
the first bart simpson or mickey mouse
they didn't look great either you can
hire people later
but when it's authentic
and you gotta think of yourself you know
i don't know you well maybe you do love
the idea of having dinner with 20 people
maybe you do want to have people meet
you in the green room before a show
maybe you do want to serenade somebody
on stage
justin bieber in his prime if he had an
nft that if you bought it it also gave
you the ability to sit in a chair and
get serenaded
some [ __ ] rich [ __ ] here would have
bought it for his 15 year old daughter
for a hundred thousand dollars
so you got to think about the strategy
and it has to start with what you're
willing to do
i see you see what i mean because it's
not just the art it's a contract if you
want it to be most people just make it
about art
but that's like thinking in 1995 the
internet was just about search engines
it was a lot more
you can start you know back to being a
humongous global artist
maybe your nft is your membership club
maybe it's your fan club maybe you put
out a hundred thousand nfts for a
hundred dollars a piece and if you buy
it you're part of the fan club
photos access
discounts on tickets
it's powerful
and what's cool about it is unlike when
the beatles had a fan club in the 60s
when somebody takes a piece of art like
shakira
and sells it they love you but now they
don't like you as much you know how that
happens fans right
when they sell it because there's only
100 000 of them you get a royalty
very big
this is a big
what are you thinking boyd no i mean
yeah i mean that's that's what we want
we were saying we just want to get to
know each other you know we've been
trying to meet you for so long and we
know you love cars motorcycles are what
type of like four-wheelers right yeah
yeah i'm saying whatever you want to
talk about man i know
yeah man and we're here for you know i
think you probably have a sense of us
we love
music and culture and like we believe in
karma
i'm i'm not interested i don't need
anything so it's good to just give game
oh i think you guys should talk about
family you know we're really filming
this and people are going to see this
like
family means so much to him and i know
it's everything to you it's like
like just it's good grandparents like
everything it's just family they're all
back from puerto rico
i mean other than that stuff i mean the
next he's going on world tour like they
just said they're doing the first like
what what what was the first what was
the first moment where it started really
what was if i asked you what was the
moment where it
turned
oh my god
that turned
like
that you started seeing this calling you
start seeing the light right
because remember at the end of the day
um
artists when they start they have a
dream right of course they have a dream
to become an artist they have a dream to
be famous to have a dream to accomplish
a lot of things
um
when
came out
he came out of the face on myspace
is it really yes yeah he's so organic
and so real that when he came now he
came out
just like he said
imagine if you come and you become an
energy artist yeah
and you release everything right
platform or whatever it is
right so he just came on just like that
he came out on my streets put in a
musical when
back in
2008
2010 11 11 11 2011.
nine ten nine ten nine ten
yeah
i'm there
and that was the first
no no that was
okay when you start putting music and
people around yeah of course people are
you know
i remember
that that's when we knew each other yeah
i remember
when everything turned and jock when
everything turned and we went to like oh
my god like
the two was all across the world to
travel until it was
a record called best hasta being
when the river came
killed
what year was that that was 2012
2014 one day
at that time
i remember
what was it so much momentum
that's what's so amazing about
art
in general
also
look at [ __ ] everybody well this song
that they're talking about right now
they dropped it blew up organic like no
money no big music later right
the different
mind of another artist
my career
is very organic
because
when i started
anthony campbell
can you grab that right next to you
this one yeah
you see this this is my report card
in high school
you see this spanish
i got a d
[Music]
go ahead i want to hear that though what
was he saying so when when
so like i said we started with the hard
copies yes and then when this world
changed the digital world it was like
it was like it was like
a booming ahead you know just recently
because you just started seeing
like all these new artists
coming up
coming up and landing on top of you
after all the effort and all the hard
work they did
you know all around was that frustrating
yeah i respect that
i get it
i get it because as an entrepreneur
when i was building everything when the
internet was impossible nobody used it
and then in 2000
so i was in 98
and then in 2005 67
i'm seeing companies
get two million dollars in funding at a
20 million dollar valuation
but it's funny that sat with me very
short
two seconds on my mind
you can't control
when you're born
there's gonna be people that you look to
that's you looked and said they had it
easy
they're gonna say the same [ __ ] about a
12 year old right now that's going to
use nfts
to not do record deals
crazy artists are giving up 80 percent
of the action on the back end
for upfront cash
and kids are going to keep 80 percent
sell [ __ ] more get more money from
their fans for nfts
and feel better
because
90 percent of artists don't feel great
about the company making the money and
now literally now
the people are going to make money
besides the artist are the earliest fans
who believed in the artist
mike when he fully realized what i'm
saying is going to wake up one day in 9
months 19 months 39 months to be like
[ __ ]
all that skill i had
it was good for clout gary
thought it was smart and that was good
for my career in my 20s and 30s
but i could have bought
he wrote about nicki minaj when she had
four thousand followers on twitter
if she would have sold her masters
he would have bought
eight hundred dollars worth and probably
would be making four thousand dollars a
day on nicki music
today that's what's gonna happen artists
are gonna become like stocks and
startups
fans are gonna bet
it's gonna be cool
cool it's gonna be very cool yeah
100 that's that's what's gonna happen
with nfts contract
spotify royalties come in it's gonna
know the 99 people that own nfts from
the original
masters
just like this jockey and all that just
gonna distribute the money i'm gonna
hold the nft
of course it's gonna be beautiful art no
different than an album caller
but it's gonna represent point two
percent of all the music royalties
it's gonna be a big game for us
but we do well listen to a lot of music
decide do you believe
bet on the person
it's cool
so nice that's why i love web 3 so much
this new
world about who's making the money the
artist and the people that most believe
in it
imagine buying one percent of all
nirvana
royalties
because you saw them in a
bar in seattle in 1990
it's [ __ ] cool
think about how it uplifts communities
who do you think is going to buy the
first nft the people from the
neighborhood
and then you also have 4 000 10 000
people who are not just fans who are
financially incentivized for you to win
what the [ __ ] do you think they're gonna
do
they're gonna share your music 24 hours
a day
nfts are gonna change music in a very
big way beautiful
in beautiful way
beautiful
what about what about collaborations
these days one thing mike knows that i'm
passionate about
passionate
because obviously you've won so much in
your universe
but what about the idea of doing music
with
madonna or cher
or taylor swift how do you think about
collaborations to broaden awareness
i think the number one thing
the number one
thing
that you guys could all help him with is
make him listen to a lot of different
music see if he falls in love with
anything and then do things with them
if he falls in love with one song from
an emerging k-pop
band and you guys get together in la
and you catch it right changes his whole
career yeah
he's done that a lot
on the line i know that that's why i'm
bringing it up i
i believe
from my eyes from afar it's one of the
biggest reasons he's here today the way
he is
i think you should broaden it period to
the world country k-pop
edm whatever the [ __ ]
everything doji
it's just you know what it is for him
it's what you do for me
if they're just every week it's almost
like exercise here's 12 songs that he
would never listen to
to just listen
you know what it's just like me yeah
it's it's mike gives me a ton of new
music it's one every 40 songs
100 songs where i'll text him i may not
talk to him for two months and then out
of nowhere i'm like who's this
yeah
it's real and that's why we've been
waiting to meet you for so long when
this came across the radar gary all kept
yes now we need to finally
because when we like someone we like
them yeah because because two things i
believe in
authenticity and strategy
i'm not confused how you guys got to
this office
it's you're very smart it's how it's by
the way it's how i got to this office
but i do think it could be very big for
you
what i love notice what i'm saying i'm
not saying make just find the people
that are already winning because i
already know that it has to be authentic
to you
i'm saying to the crew just load up his
[ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] he listens to
music to
12 a week
i don't know if you work out or when you
go to sleep or however you like it
traveling right that's what i you know
it's been harder for me to listen to
this [ __ ] because i'm very good when i'm
traveling on a plane because while i'm
working i'll listen
and zoom and everything i don't have the
rhythm that i had before so
but
i think that could be an incredible
thing you can do for him
re even if you have to add somebody new
to the team because i'm sure everyone's
busy really new new [ __ ] like who's
popping in [ __ ]
sweden
there's a new movement in europe right
now
with a new sound
and we've been paying attention to
because
believe me what you're saying is
you're not doing that he's he don't come
he don't just
steps in one circle you know he likes to
jump around from side to side
and if you see if you follow
his career he's done
a bandsaw album he's done a regular and
he's done the trap album
it's why i'm giving you the advice i
have i know
but to your point in a certain like in a
pocket
and i'm saying [ __ ] it
go do country
you know you know we have a real good
connection
and
[Music]
um were talking about a few weeks ago
that man we should come home with just
rock cop
and rock bro
especially if you want to do it i don't
scare i'm not i know
no other artists in the night what time
is it
one minute until the apac thing yeah can
you just hit up marcus and tell them
i'll be five minutes i just want to
chill on them
you guys are all saying his mentality he
loves cars and motorcycles or anything
he was saying i'm like i'm like a person
making these cars and this is a
prototype like his new hit it's like
this is an option it blew up but he
likes making things that are like better
than the last to him he's an artist you
know
so trying things loving it where where
are you where do you live
pr here and any anywhere else miami
mm-hmm i am up here
what about um
how are you guys thinking about products
water anything water
apparel
we
would love to do this type of thing
you're just
you're so focused
[ __ ]
if it doesn't make sense why do it
remember 100 once you lose the
opportunity as far as i agree
for example nft how about if i do that
with the wrong
person with the wrong 100
100 so there's i would say there's a
time
for everything
there's a time for everything
you can't rush him you can't what's
going on with uh obviously i know what's
going on with you on instagram but i
don't know what is what's going on with
you on tick-tock
you know my teeth always die
it goes viral instantly and we're just
talking about i know you're in a rush
but like not just viral
but we were saying maybe someone should
document just his face goes viral like
he might not love the app but
killing it how many followers does he
have on it 2.5 million right
now
it should be way more
no of course but
he doesn't [ __ ] with it you don't [ __ ]
with it at all you know
the crime is about to hit 20. youtube is
about to take 20 mil it's like it's a
100 million across you're gonna have to
figure it out yeah you're gonna have to
yeah i need it you're gonna be upset
and you've been around the game long
enough you saw what happened to myspace
i did the
you can't
you have to get more serious
and like it's the same thing with my
weight
and my strength
for eight years i got my [ __ ] together
finally but i hate it every day
and that's how you're gonna have to
treat tic toc until you like it yeah
you're gonna have you're gonna have no
choice you have too much ambition
too much
yeah
you gotta be posting two times a day
you've posted five times since may
and i i what he did more than what i
thought i thought he did
it you know
listen we have this limited time
together
obviously let's start talking more often
like we love doing we'll help no matter
how happy to help you with anything
but this
you can't [ __ ] around with you're gonna
you're gonna lose labyrinth you're gonna
lose leverage
you know how powerful that instagram has
been for you
this is gonna eat it up
there's not a 17 year old that
you're too young you have too much to do
you've got to figure it out how long do
you think
it's gonna last
a lot longer
than
the concept of ignoring it
[Laughter]
right think about
knowing your journey think about all the
artists that were bigger than you that
disregarded all the platforms
eventually you become successful enough
to become who you made fun of on the way
up
and that's the danger
eventually you become successful enough
to become who you made fun of on the way
up because they didn't understand it
sometimes [ __ ] comes natural sometimes
just a little difficult but when you
want it
you gotta fight for it yes
the pro the problem is it was easy in
2010
you'll do anything
when you're hungry you'll eat anything
[Laughter]
in 2021
thank goodness thank god for all the
hard work all of you put in a little
less hungry
a little more bling
a little more followers and you get
passive on where the kids [ __ ] with
then you become vulnerable
and then the 19 year old version of you
takes your [ __ ]
yeah for sure but even with how you
always say gary always says listen and
like study like if he loves cars and
motorcycles there's so much cars and
motorcycles on a tic toc all day long
and if any of those people you jump in
their comments or
or it's like anything it's like a coach
it's like anything if it doesn't come
natural for him to do it then one of the
four of you good looking characters need
to be near him all the time and just
[ __ ] make it happen
if you start [ __ ] with people on tick
tock that's like an article ready to go
pitchfork whoever's like whoa why did
furuko just jump in all his fans
comments you know people go crazy yeah
more importantly it's where attention is
in 1985 it's a good idea to be on mtv
every hour
in 2011 not as much in 221 it's not even
on your mind
tick tock isn't something you can just
disregard
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon